franchises are inescapable the endless
sequel format works well with
blockbusters like Star Wars and The Fast
and Furious movies able to make hits
with every release but there are some
movies out there that would maybe just
be better off left alone what are the
first films or standalone great for
bargains in flops here are some upcoming
sequels or we just can't believe are
being made wedding crashes to the 2005
hit wedding crashers is finally ready to
crash theaters again in the form of a
sequel according to Variety the original
grossed over 200 million dollars
domestically over a decade ago and now
wedding crashers director David Dobkin
is laying the groundwork for a sequel
that could include double-oh-seven
himself Daniel Craig dobkin wrote on
Quora Vince Owen and myself sat around
at Owens house one day and broke the
story it was really funny we want to
Daniel Craig to be the ultimate wedding
crasher with this sexy body and a speedo
and the two guys would be incredibly
threatened by him provided dobkin can
tap into the same chemistry energy and
knock down laughs the all-star cast
someone for the first film this could
actually be a sequel worth waiting for
then again fans hope the same thing for
dylan de 2 and look how that turned out
all the may yes on both counts American
Pie 5 since 1999 the American Pie
franchise has given the world three
additional servings of Jim our change
Michelle and Stifler
and that's not even counting the fourth
straight-to-dvd spinner which were all
pretty much well in the wake of 2012's
American Reunion the fourth the optical
installment of the franchise
Tork was already turning to a fifth film
in 2015
Tara Reid revealed that a fifth chapter
in the raunchy comedy saga was indeed in
the work and that they may be doing it
in Las Vegas and as surprising as it
sounds the franchise might still
actually be bankable American Reunion
brought in 234 million dollars worldwide
Assassin's Creed so practically from the
moment it had theaters hype for
Assassin's Creed fell even harder than
Michael Fassbender stunt-double
even before the film opened however
executive producer Patrick Crowley told
GameSpot that he fully expects to make
Assassin's Creed the start of a film
choice saying it's not a one-off
everybody expects that this movie will
continue star and producer Michael
Fassbender also told cinema blend in
December 2016
but tentative plans were already laid
out for a film trilogy this is the sort
of origin to the story we have an idea
of where he's going to go over the next
two films we kind of did a three film
arc both Fassbender and Crowley have
been tight-lipped about the sequence of
elements ever since
but despite bombing in the box-office
foreign ticket sales of Lloyds to
Assassin's Creed's gross well past its
production budget of 125 million dollars
making this sequel or the more likely
gremlins free more than 30 years after
gremlins arrived in theatres and more
than 25 years after its follow-up
gremlins to the new batch underwhelmed
at the box office
Starbucks Galligan has confirmed that
gremlins 3 has been given the go-ahead
along with an extra piece of good news
it's not going to be a reboot will not
be a remake in any way shape or form the
third installment in the franchise
reportedly has Steven Spielberg and
original gremlins screenwriter Chris
Columbus attached and Karl Ellsworth who
wrote to Serbia Red Dawn and The Last
House on the Left
is on board to write the script all that
aside rumors have been swirling about
the third gremlins for years we'll see
if it actually happens of time June the
last of the enforcers you know the last
of the enforces is a follow-up to goon
starring Sean William Scott with a
supporting cast are both Liev Schreiber
Elisha Cuthbert and Wyatt Russell Jay
Baruchel who also played a supporting
role in the original have signed on to
direct the sequel Parrish L told Metro
News Toronto he's taking the job
seriously and it doesn't want to let
dune fans down you have no choice but to
give them something that you think is
better than the first movie so that's
why it took five years between the first
two movies it's because we wanted to
make sure we got it right Zombieland -
it's the return of the double top
in late 2016
Deadpool writers Paul Wernick and
referees revealed to Kevin Smith on
geeking out that they received backing
to pursue a sequel through their
surprise head a zombie land sequel has
been discussed numerous times since the
original racked up over a hundred
million dollars during its 2009 box
office run but those talks have
obviously all come to naught so while
Wernick and Reese's excitement is
infectious we're still taking this with
the teeniest grain of salt for now saw
legacy this is the horror franchise that
just won't go away
so legacy will be the eighth installment
in the franchise
that's not exactly surprising but since
the last one was called saw 3d the final
chapter well we kind of hoped it really
was while not much is known about the
plots it seems safe to assume so legacy
will involve a group of people being
forced to play sadistic games to stay
alive Michael and peter spierig directed
and it's scheduled to drop October 27th
2017 just in time for Halloween the
predator after a long painful run of
cheesy Cashion's
it's about time we got decent predator
movie and shamed blacks 2018
installments called simply the predator
is already looking like a killer black
who wrote Lethal Weapon and directed the
nice guys
among plenty of other Hollywood classics
has been touched to write and direct and
he said he plans to push the franchise
forward with a sequel rather than a
reboot black who actually played a big
part in the original told Collider he
was reluctant to take the gig until Fox
told him he'd have enough money to
deliver the movie he really wanted to
make given blacks track record for
quality action-packed bucks Buster's
like Lethal Weapon and Iron Man 3 this
bodes well frankly the most unbelievable
thing about the sequel is that after so
many years it might actually be
completely awesome yeah stick around
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you